speaking of patreon okay we have a
fantastic countdown that is it's fierce
fair to say it's accelerating I think it
is accelerating I think well I don't
know we'll run the math on it in a
moment the background is what April I
mean that depends how far we back we
want to go in 1984 I was born in Buenos
Aires Argentina I eventually moved to
the US and started the David Pakman show
and when we got to April of 2017 in that
story we launched a patreon fundraising
page at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show we have a target of 2100 donors
which when reached will trigger I guess
got to be careful using that word these
days it will release the critical
thinking miniseries that we have been
working on and that 2,100 patron goal is
something that we have been inching
closer and closer to now for several
weeks last week I told you we needed a
hundred more patrons then late last week
we were down to needing only 85 we are
now down as of this morning we had 2000
43 patrons we are 57 patrons away from
the 2,100 milestone and we are moving
ahead on this critical thinking
miniseries the introduction to the
critical thinking miniseries is done it
looks really cool it is fully animated
by producer Noah Ferguson we'll be
talking about arguments we'll be talking
about logical fallacies we'll be talking
about I don't know epistemology and
media literacy it's gonna be absolutely
fantastic but we've got to get to 2,100
patrons to do it I am worried I'm gonna
be very upfront I'm worried about the
upcoming February 1st date I know
because on the first day of the month
when patreon goes to run everyone's
pledges usually between 3 & 5 percent of
the patrons have credit cards that have
expired or get declined and we are
knocked away from the number of patrons
so I think it would be best if in the
next 72 hours before February 1st we can
do this which really it only requires
about 18 new patrons per day like it's
totally doable if we decide hey let's do
this thing
and whether it's a dollar contribution
or 10 or $100 we're just trying to get
to 2,100 patrons yeah that's why we're
coming to you now with this rallying cry
because that's a rallying cry in a week
if we don't get it done it's just gonna
be a regular cry it's gonna be a regular
cry and then we'll be trying to get it
done during February yes but from up
from a much lower number than 2043
Patriots now have so let's make it
happen patreon.com slash David Pakman
show